now to washington and president biden's
historic decision on student loans the
measure could affect up to 43 million
americans including many who have been
carrying this debt for decades however
not everyone is celebrating the
president's decision nancy cordes is at
the white house nancy good morning
good morning nate lots of major changes
for federal student loan holders for
starters president biden announced
yesterday that he is extending the pause
in federal student loan payments one
last time until january but it was his
announcement on federal student loan
forgiveness that as anticipated drew
cheers from one quarter and criticism
from another
it kind of lifts a lot of stress off
people on college campuses from coast to
coast excitement spread so quickly
tuesday some student loan websites
crashed i've racked up a lot of debt and
it would be
a huge financial blessing to like
get rid of at least even a little bit of
that weight was lifted off my shoulders
mostly for my parents because it
stresses them out like a lot the
president's plan will forgive ten
thousand dollars worth of student debt
for individuals making less than twenty
125 thousand dollars a year or couples
earning less than two hundred fifty
thousand people who got pell grants as
low income students could see their debt
cut by twenty thousand dollars an entire
generation is now saddled with
unsustainable debt and even if you
graduate you may not have access to
middle class life that the college
degree once provided the move was hailed
by progressives this is a great day and
slammed by republicans if you owe money
as challenging as it is
you have an obligation to pay it back it
is hurting people who paid off their own
debts even adjusting for inflation the
average cost of a four-year college
education has nearly tripled since
eighty it's now about twenty nine
thousand dollars a year this plan is
really a band-aid and it doesn't solve
uh the core incentive problem in
american higher education so i think
it's very likely that we're going to be
having the same discussions in five or
ten years
how much is all of this loan forgiveness
going to cost well the white house says
it can't answer that question because
they still don't know how many people
are going to go ahead and claim that ten
thousand dollar or twenty thousand
dollar benefit it is important to note
nate that all student loans received
after june 30th will not be eligible for
relief
so nancy if people think that they are
eligible for relief then what should
they do
well there's an online form that they're
going to have to fill out but because
this is also new that form doesn't exist
yet so for now if people think they are
eligible they can go to the u.s
department of education website and sign
up to get an alert when that form is
ready which the white house says should
be sometime in the coming weeks
nancy thank you